[Applaus]
[Musik]
lass mich am Anfang eine kleine Frage
stellen was ist die teuerste Waffe der
Geschichte nein es ist weder eine
Atombombe noch Israels eierndom die
teuerste Waffe der Geschichte ist ein
Kampfjet die Loki Martin F35 Lightning 2
und ich weiß schon was jetzt viele von
euch denken vor allen Dingen die sich
mit diesem Thema gut auskennen Marc das
stimmt doch nicht es gibt ja viel
teurere Kampfflugzeuge als die F35 und
da habt ihr auch vollkommen Recht eine
F22 kann z.B etwa 300 Millionen Dollar
pro Stück kosten wäre die F35 pro Stück
weniger als 90 Millionen Dollar kostet
aber was dieses Flugzeug so unglaublich
teuer machte die Kosten für seine
Entwicklung haltet euch lieber fest denn
diese Zahl wird euch schocken 400
Milliarden Dollar um das ganze mal ins
Verhältnis zu setzen und euch eine
kleine Vorstellung davon zu geben das
ist mehr als das gesamte
Bruttoinlandsprodukt eines Landes wie
Ägypten und hier gleich der nächste
Vergleich der Internationale Raumstation
ISS die auch nicht billig war kostet du
nur 150 Milliarden Dollar aber wartet
noch einen Moment denn das ist noch
nicht das Ende der veranstange wenn wir
über Militärausgaben sprechen vergessen
wir oft einen wichtigen Teil die
Wartungskosten das sind nämlich jede
kosten die es braucht um alle F35
kampfbereit zu halten Reparaturen
Treibstoff Upgrades und so weiter wenn
wir also all das zusammenzählen können
wir sagen dass die Gesamtkosten des F35
Programms am Ende mehr als 1,1 Billionen
Dollar betragen und ja das sind echte
deutsche Billionen mit einem großen B
wenn euch diese ganzen Zahlen jetzt
verwirren denk mal kurz darüber nach das
ist mehr als die Hälfte des gesamten
Budgets der Europäischen Union ein
Budget das wir hier auf visualpolitik
schon mehrfach kritisiert haben als für
uns nach einer richtigen Orgie einer
öffentlichen Ausgaben riecht vielleicht
könnte man dieses Budget ja noch damit
rechtfertigen dass es für das
Wohlergehen eines Großteils von Europa
eingesetzt wird aber in unserem Fall
geht es ja um horrende Summen nur um
dasjenige Flugzeug zu entwickeln das
hier gerade auf dem Bildschirm seht
und lasst euch nicht davon täuschen dass
die F35 von einem privaten Unternehmen
entwickelt wurde das ganze Geld für die
Entwicklung stammt selbstverständlich
aus dem Taschen der Steuerzahler der USA
Großbritanniens der Niederlande und
viele weitere Länder ich werde euch
später in diesem Video erklären warum
und was euch jetzt wahrscheinlich alle
fragt ist die F35 wirklich dieses ganze
Geld wert ist sie wirklich so toll nun
das ist die gleiche Frage die man sich
in Washington schon seit Jahren stellt
von Hillary Clinton über John McCain bis
zu Donald Trump haben viele US-Politiker
das f35-programm scharf kritisiert sogar
einen Maske stellte die F35 in Frage und
bis heute scheint die Kontroverse kein
Ende zu nehmen gut sicher habt ihr euch
schon das öfteren gefragt ob
Militärausgaben wirklich so wichtig sind
natürlich stellt niemand in Frage dass
jedes Land ein Militär braucht na ja
wenn wir mal von Scherz wollten wie
tufallo oder Panama absehen die uns noch
das ganze Skript durcheinander bringen
falls ihr aber mal Lust hättet einfach
mal so ohne großen Aufwand eines fremdes
Land zu besetzen hier wärt ihr an der
richtigen Adresse aber scheiß beiseite
wohin ist im Fall der F35 das ganze
selbst geflossen warum hat das F35
Projekt so viel Geld gekostet wie
funktioniert überhaupt der Waffenmarkt
und hatte Elon muskrecht dass die F35 im
Luftkrieg der Zukunft gegen Drohnen
keine Chance haben wird passt gut auf
denn am Beispiel der F35 werden wir
viele Dinge über die Rüstungsindustrie
Geostrategie und moderne Luftkampf
lernen und all diese hochinteressanten
Fragen beantworten aber zuerst werfen
wir einen kurzen Blick auf die
Geschichte
[Musik]
ein Kampfjet um sie alle zu vereinen
vielleicht wird euch das ja überraschen
aber die ursprüngliche Idee der F35 war
Kosten zu sparen ja ihr habt tatsächlich
richtig gehört unsere Geschichte beginnt
in den 1990er Jahren der Kalte Krieg war
gerade vorbeigegangen und das bedeutet
dass es keine Supermarkt wie die
Sowjetunion ergab mit der man sich in
Sachen Rüstung messen konnte deshalb
beschlossen sowohl das US-Militär als
auch viele andere Verbündete
Streitkräfte Kostenoptimierung
vorzunehmen zumindest bei ihrem
Kampfjets und wie sollte das gehen nun
ja erstens in denen sie sich bei der
Entwicklung eines einheitlichen
Kampfjets für alle Länder
zusammenschlossen mit anderen Worten die
USA Großbritannien Kanada die
Niederlande und viele andere Verbündete
haben sich zusammengetan um das Joint
Strike Fighter Programm zu gründen man
könnte sagen dass dieses Programm so
etwas wie eine Wunschliste mit all jenen
Spezifikationen war die dieser neue
Kampfjet haben sollte auf diese Weise
konnten sie den Rüstungsfirmen einen
viel größeren Auftrag erteilen und wenn
du eine größere Bestellung aufgibst
entstehen Skalen Vorteile und die Kosten
können gesenkt werden macht Sinn oder
und was haben diese Länder in ihren
Brief an den Weihnachtsmann alles
reingeschrieben nun um die Kosten noch
weiter zu optimieren taten sie etwas
ähnliches was billigfluglinge wie
Ryanair Jahre später auch tun würden ein
einziges Flugzeugmodell verwenden das
für alle Aufgaben eingesetzt werden kann
denn ja normalerweise ist jedes
Kampfflugzeug für ganz bestimmte
Einsatzsituation konzipiert die Harrier
zum Beispiel ist ein fantastisches
Flugzeug zu Unterstützung von
Bodentruppen weil sie unter anderem
senkrecht landen und starten kann als
wäre sie ein Hubschrauber dadurch kann
sie in beinahe allen Geländetypen
eingesetzt werden allerdings ist die
Harrier nicht für Angriff auf andere
Kampfflugzeuge geeignet weil sie keine
Überschallgeschwindigkeit erreichen kann
wenn man also für den Luftkampf gerüstet
sein will braucht man zusätzlich ein
Flotte von F16 und das bedeutet dass man
für jedes Flugzeugmodell immer spezielle
Wartungstechniker dabei haben muss und
das bedeutet wiederum Kosten und noch
mehr kosten
der Masterplan der US-Armee sah also ein
Kampfflugzeug vor dass alle Bedürfnisse
vereinen sollte ein multifunktionales
Flugzeug das erstens die Schallmauer
durchbrechen kannst zweitens
senkrechtstarten und landen kann und
drittens und darauf wurde viel Wert
gelegt ein Tarnkappen Flugzeug sein
sollte das heißt dass das Radargeräten
erheblich erschwert wird dieses Flugzeug
zu entdecken schon in den 90er Jahren
gab es Flugzeuge die einige dieser
Eigenschaften hatten aber alle drei
Aspekte in einem einzigen Kampfflugzeug
zu vereinen bei einem noch nie da
gewesenes Wunderwerk der Technik das
Überraschungsei der Kampfjets die
Tarnkappen über Schale Senkrechtstarter
Wollmilchsau also wurde mit diesem Brief
an den Weihnachtsmann eine Wettbewerb
veranstaltet an dem die führenden
Rüstungsunternehmen der Welt teilnahmen
und schließlich führte im Jahr 2001 die
Jury den Gewinnern und jetzt passt gut
auf Rocket Marketing mit den join Strike
Fighter Wettbewerb behaltet dieses
Unternehmen gut im Gedächtnis seit diese
Firma den Wettbewerb gewann hat sich
hier Aktienkurs versefacht
denk mal drüber nach Lockheed Martin hat
ein Flugzeug entwickelt das fast alle
Kampfflugzeug flotten der USA und ihre
Verbündeten ersetzen konnte um euch eine
Vorstellung davon zu geben allein das
Pentagon hat mir als 2400 S35 Kampfjets
bestellt
2400 dieser Zuschlag war ein echter
Segen für das Unternehmen aber zur
gleichen Zeit begann auch der große F35
Albtraum schnallt euch lieber an denn
was jetzt kommt wird ein Ritt auf dem
finanziellen Schleudersitz
die teuerste Waffe der Geschichte
die F-35 war kurz davor Realität zu
werden logite martin hatte das Schweizer
Taschenmesser unter dem Kampfjet
entwickelt es war getarnt Flug mit
Überschallgeschwindigkeit konnte
senkrecht starten und landen und hatte
die neueste Software und dafür
blätterten sowohl die USA als auch alle
anderen Länder die am Programm beteiligt
waren 298 Milliarden Dollar auf den
Tisch das klingt jetzt vielleicht nach
einer ganzen Menge Geld aber denkt auch
das ist hier um die Erneuerung fast ihre
gesamten Kampfjet flotten ging gut aber
wo lag nun eigentlich das Problem na ja
das Problem trat dann auf als es in die
Massenproduktion ging
zunächst einmal gibt es nicht nur ein
F35 Modell sondern eigentlich drei die
f35a für den Luftkampf die f35b für
vertikale Staats- und Landungen und die
f-35c die mit klappbaren Flügeln
ausgestattet war ursprünglich sollten
diese drei Modelle sehr ähnlich
konstruiert sein aber als die Produktion
voranschrift hatten nach und nach kleine
Probleme auf vor allem mit der Software
es stellte sich heraus dass ich die
verschiedenen F35 Modelle einer nämlich
gar nicht so ähnlich sein können und in
vielen Fällen außerdem spezielles
Personal für die Wartung erfordert aber
wenn das nur das einzige Problem gewesen
wäre
da gab es nämlich auch ein Prinzip
innerhalb von Logitech Martin dass sich
concurrent development nannte zu deutsch
verteilte gleichzeitige Entwicklung nun
was bedeutet das also anstatt zu warten
bis alle Entwürfe für die
Massenproduktion fertig sind beginnt das
Unternehmen mit der Herstellung von
Flugzeugen als Beta-Versionen dann
werden in der Forschungs- und
Entwicklungsabteilung nach und nach
Verbesserungen an den bereits
entwickelten Flugzeugen vorgenommen die
Idee hinter dieser Strategie war
eigentlich die Produktion zu
beschleunigen aber stattdessen hat sie
das Gegenteil bewirkt
jedes Mal wenn Verbesserungen an diesen
beta-flugzeugen vorgenommen wurden
taucht neue Probleme auf jedes Mal wenn
der fehlerhydra ein Kopf abgeschlagen
wurde wuchsen zwei neue nach und all
diese Probleme hatten zwei Dinge zur
Folge lange Verzögerungen und eine Menge
Kosten sehr hohe Kosten extrem hohe
Kosten unvorstellbar extrem hohe Kosten
schaut es euch selbst an die F-35
Programmkosten steigt nach neuerster
Schätzung auf 406,5 Milliarden Dollar
ihr habt richtig gehört was ursprünglich
weniger als 300 Milliarden Dollar waren
was schon viel viel Geld ist wuchs auf
über 400 Milliarden Dollar an und hier
scheiden sich die Geister einige sagen
dass all diese Probleme nachvollziehbar
sein aber es gibt nicht wenige die sich
darüber beschweren dass es dem
Unternehmen an anreißend so
Kostenoptimierung mangele aber warum
sollte lokit Martin auch so hart daran
arbeiten wenn sie erst einmal den
Zuschlag erhalten haben und nun das
investierte Geld für die Entwicklung
ausgeben wird niemand das Projekt
abbrechen das ist nämlich für die Kunden
die gesamte Investition einfach
wegzuwerfen also waren sowohl die USA
als auch die anderen Verbündeten dazu
gezwungen alle Budget Überschreitungen
zu bezahlen um schlussendlich wenigstens
die lang ersehnte F35 zu bekommen tja
das in was ich die auftraggeberländer da
hinein manufriert haben nennt sich
klassisch login-situation und wenn ihr
mir ein kleines Wortspiel erlaubt der
Hersteller sollte sich nun ganz
transparent in Login Martin umbenennen
aber das ist noch nicht das Ende der
Veranstaltung die F35 ist nicht nur in
der Entwicklung teuer sie ist auch teuer
in der Wartung und im Einsatz der Flug
eines F15 ex-jägers kostet z.B
durchschnittlich etwa 28.000 pro Stunde
eine F35 Lightning 2 kostet mehr als 45
000 $ pro Stunde mit anderen Worten ja
die F35 ist ein richtig toller Kampfjet
aber du musst es dir schon zweimal
überlegen bevor du damit eine Spritztour
machst was jedoch viel viel günstiger
ist als ein F35 spaß-flug aktiv etwas
für die Unabhängigkeit echter
Qualitätsmedien zu tun durch eine kleine
Spende an visualpolitik über den Link in
der Beschreibung unter diesem Video ja
diese Spenden sind wirklich sehr wichtig
für uns überlebenswichtig denn ich muss
euch wieder etwas gestehen ich habe
einen Sponsor der wirklich viel Geld
geboten hat in die Wüste geschickt es
handelt es sich um eine
investment-geschichte die übrigens auf
ganz ganz vielen anderen Kanälen
beworben wird aber ich habe mich gefragt
würde ich dieser Firma auch nur einen
Cent meines eigenen Geldes anvertrauen
nein um also ein reines Gewissen zu
haben müsste ich so viele Risikohinweise
an diese Werbung dranhängen dass sie am
Ende sowieso nicht bereit gewesen wären
dafür zu bezahlen daher haben wir es
lieber ganz sein lassen auch wenn wir
dadurch auf so viel Geld verzichtet
haben dass man damit gleich mehrere
Videos hätte finanzieren können denn ich
bleibe dabei lieber um freiwillige
Spenden betteln wie es manche ignorante
Kommentatoren nennen als ich von Leuten
finanzieren zu lassen die euch unseren
geliebten Zuschauern das Geld aus der
Tasche ziehen wollen ohne eine faire und
erwünschte Gegenleistung zu erbringen
dies gilt gleichermaßen für zwielichtige
Werbetreibende wie für ausufernde
zwangsgebührensysteme also danke für all
eure Unterstützung wer schätzen diese
wirklich von Herzen und unsere
Prinzipien und unsere Seele auch in
Zukunft nicht verkaufen so und jetzt
zurück zur S35 und zwei weiteren
spannenden Fragen die euch vielleicht
stellt
erstens sind die F35 Jets schon im
Einsatz nun ja nach unzähligen
Verzögerungen kamen 2015 endlich die
ersten Kampf gegen F35 heraus aber auch
heute mehr als 20 Jahre nach dem
lockheet Martin den Auftrag erhalten hat
sind doch tausende Flugzeugen nicht
fertiggestellt die zweite Frage ist war
dieser Kampfjet wirklich so einen Haufen
Geldwert nur genau das werden wir uns
jetzt ansehen
ein fliegender Supercomputer
[Musik]
was du gerade auf dem Bildschirm siehst
ist eines der wichtigsten Teile der F-35
der Helm
stellt euch vor jeder einzelne dieser
Helme kostet mehr als 400.000 Dollar
aber was ist so besonders an ihm nun
unter anderem ermöglicht er den Piloten
das Flugzeug so zu steuern als befinde
er sich dahinter wie auf einem
fliegenden Teppich das heißt er kann die
Außenseite seines eigenen Flugzeugs
sehen wie in einem Videospiel all das
ist in vielen Radargeräten und
hochsensiblen Infrarotsensoren der F35
zu verdanken sie ist nicht irgendein
Kampfflugzeug sie ist ein fliegender
Supercomputer und wenn wir uns mal
anhören was diejenigen über diesen Helm
sagen die mit ihm geflogen sind ist ein
echtes Wunderwerk in vielen Fällen kann
man sogar Befehle per sprach erteilen
halt so wie es Siri aber aufgemotzt fürs
Militär die F35 sammelt alle
Informationen und teilt diese sowohl mit
den unterstützungseinheiten am Boden als
auch mit anderen Flugzeugen und das ist
eine echte Revolution im Bereich der
Kampfflugzeuge aber natürlich ist es
sehr kompliziert ein Kampfjet zu fliegen
zum einen gibt es im Cockpit jede Menge
Knöpfe auf die Du achten musst aber
vergiss nicht wir fliegen ja nicht nur
wir befinden uns mitten im Gefecht
du musst also auf das Fliegen selbst
achten und gleichzeitig den Feind
aufspüren auf ihn schießen und ihn daran
hindern auf dich zu schießen das ist
schon ein echtes Chaos die F35
verarbeitet daher alle externen
Informationen und sendet klarer und
direkte Meldungen und Befehle an den
Piloten darüber hinaus kann sie auch
Informationen mit Panzern Raketen
Batterien und natürlich mit anderen F35
austauschen so kann das Los zum Beispiel
automatisch erkennen wo sich ein
gegnerisches Radar befindet versteht ihr
jetzt warum die Software der 35 so einen
substanziellen Teil der Probleme
ausmachte sie ist einerseits ein
wesentlicher und unglaublich wertvoller
Bestandteil dieses Kampfjets und
andererseits unermesslich kompliziert
man könnte sagen dass die F35 nicht
einfach ein normales Flugzeug ist sie
ist ein ganzes System zum automatischen
Austausch von Informationen auf dem
Schlachtfeld Big Data für die
Kriegsführung außerdem kommt doch hinzu
dass es sich um ein Stealth Flugzeug
handelt alle F35 Modelle sind in der
Lage so zu fliegen dass sie nur sehr
schwer von einem Radar oder einer Wärme
Kamera erfasst werden können und das ist
wirklich beeindruckend ihr dürft nicht
vergessen dass das Triebwerk eines
Überschallflugzeugs sehr heiß wird um da
eine Entdeckung durch eine
Wärmebildkamera zu vermeiden beträufers
eines wahren Wunderwerks der Technik
also ziehen wir ein Fazit ist die F35
ein gutes Flugzeug die Antwort lautet
eindeutig ja es heißt sogar dass die
Lebensdauer dieses superkampfjets mehr
als 40 Jahre betragen wird anders gesagt
im Jahr 2016 werden wir immer noch von
der F-35 hören die Frage jedoch welche
sich die meisten von euch jetzt
sicherstellen werden ist folgende welche
Auswirkungen wird die F35 auf die
moderne Kriegsführung haben ist sie mehr
als ein faszinierendes Technikspielzeug
verschaffen diese ganzen Gimmicks
wirklich taktische Vorteile auf dem
Schlachtfeld der Zukunft kann Sieger
eine geostrategische Rolle einnehmen
passt auf
ein Signal an China
alles in allem kann man sagen dass die
F-35 im Moment auf der ganzen Welt
keinen echten Rivalen hat am ehesten
kommen dem NATO super Kampfjet noch die
chinesische die auf 20 oder die
russische su57 nahe aber nach Meinung
der Experten sind selbst diese
Konkurrenzmodelle bei weitem nicht so
beeindruckend wie die F35 der
amerikanischen F35 ist in ihrem Metier
eigentlich nur ein anderes Kampfflugzeug
der fünften Generation in mancherlei
Hinsicht überlegen die F22 welche auch
aus Amerika kommt allerdings steht diese
ausschließlich den USA zur Verfügung und
kostet mehr als 300 Millionen Dollar pro
Stück mit anderen Worten die F35 ist
dazu bestimmt für fast alle Verbündeten
von Uncle Sam zum Maßstab für
Kampfflugzeuge zu werden
tatsächlich waren die USA nicht mal das
erste Land das die F35 im Kampf
einsetzte nein das war Israel aber das
Wichtigste an diesen brandneuen
Kampfflugzeug ist das ist ein starkes
Signal an China sendet passt auf
Singapur befindet sich wieder ein Phase
der Beschaffung von 4F 35 DJs sollen bis
2026 geliefert werden
die USA geben grünes Licht für Japans 23
Milliarden Dollar teuren Einkauf
mehrerer F35 Japan Singapur Südkorea das
alles in Länder in Ostasien die ihre
Flugzeugflotten mit dem natojet Erneuern
eine Ausrüstung mit der China nicht
mithalten kann zumindest soweit bekannt
und all das dient nur einem Zweck die
Nachbarin Chinas rüsten auf um eine
mögliche Expansion des reichste Mitte zu
verhindern und das tun sie indem sie
ihre militärischen Beziehungen mit den
USA stärken mit anderen Worten die F35
hilft Uncle Sam seine Verbündeten Asien
bei Laune zu halten und vielleicht sogar
noch enger an sich zu binden das gleiche
gilt für Europa wo bereits fast alle
NATO-Länder F35 gekauft haben oder
zumindest den Kauf in Erwägung ziehen um
ihre Kampfflugzeug flotten zu erneuern
natürlich wird es noch Jahre dauern bis
Lockheed markten alle erteilten Aufträge
ausführen kann und mit Problemen und
Verzögerungen scheint derweil kein Ende
in sich zu sein
aber wir können bereits heute sagen dass
die F35 zum Objekte Begierde von fast
allen Streitkräften der Welt geworden
ist sie ist also ein echter Trumpf der
USA im geo-strategischen Pokerspiel und
Bündnisse und militärallianzen denn so
mancher Staat wird es sich verdammt gut
überlegen ob er seine Streitkräfte
lieber mit oder gegen die F35 antreten
lassen will tja oder liegen die
Strategen und Druck Militärs dieser
Länder alle falsch wie Elon Musk vor
zwei Jahren in einem Tweet meinte als er
schrieb die Ära der Kampfjets sei
vorüber und die F35 hätte gegen
Kampfdrohnen keine Chance dies war von
Menschen ferngesteuert werden der meine
Serie Fähigkeit aber durch autonomes
Software ergänzt wird
[Musik]
nun vielleicht wird Elon Musk irgendwann
rechts damit haben allerdings könnte
diese Vision noch gut ein oder zwei
Generationen entfernt sein das Entfernen
des Menschen aus dem Flugzeug löst zwar
ein paar Probleme schafft aber ganz neue
der Mensch in der Maschine vereinfacht
das System als Ganzes Maske geht zum
Beispiel davon aus dass der klassische
Dogfight der sogenannte kurvenkampf in
dem zwei gegnerische Flugzeuge versuchen
in halsbrecherischen Manövern jeweils
hinter das andere zu gelangen um es dann
abzuschießen eine tragende Rolle bei der
Erlangen der Luftüberlegenheit spielt
dies ist jedoch nur Top Gun Romantik
welche uns Hollywood in die Köpfe
gesetzt hat und sie hat nur sehr wenig
mit der Realität moderner Kriegsführung
zu tun heutzutage ist die reine
Manövrierfähigkeit eines Kampfflugzeugs
gegenüber dem anderen Flugzeug nicht
mehr so wichtig die F35 muss keine
Manöver fliegen um sich hinter eine
Drohne zu setzen theoretisch würde ihr
komplexes Waffensystem die Drohnen schon
lange vor einem kurvenkampf bekämpfen
und auch schon lange bevor überhaupt
Sichtkontakt zu ihr besteht
die Drohne müsste so manövrierfähig sein
dass sie die Fähigkeiten der ankommenden
Rakete übertrifft die F35 ist eigentlich
nichts anderes als eine fliegende mit
einem Haufen Waffen und Sensoren
bestückte Antenne welche ihre
Sensordaten und die andere im Verband zu
einem großen taktischen Bild verbindet
die alles andere ausstechende
Trumpfkarte der Luft Überlegenheit heißt
heute situationsbewusstsein moderne
Kampfpiloten werden gezielt darauf
trainiert Konflikte auf Sicht eben durch
perfekte situationsbewusstsein zu
vermeiden und kein Flugzeug kann dies
besser als die F35 sogar Piloten der F22
Raptor dem tödlichsten Kampfflugzeug der
Welt bei Kampfsituation innerhalb der
Sichtweite tun alles um einen
nahkampfzug vermeiden eine feindliche
Drohne käme also gar nicht so weit dass
sie es nur mit einer Einzel F35 zu tun
hätte es besteht die Chance dass die
feindliche Drohne von der
trägerkampfgruppe oder den Samst im
Einsatzgebiet abgeschossen wird lange
bevor sie die F35 erreicht auf dem
heutigen Schlachtfeld dreht sich alles
um Synergien und wenn der Feind nicht
über eine zumindest gleichwertige
Infrastruktur verfügt wird er verlieren
sollte die Drohne in ein Luftkampf mit
Sichtkontakt eintreten würde der
drohnenpilot den Vorteil seiner
manöverfähigkeit durch das Fehlen
visuelle Sensoren an seiner Konsole
verlieren die menschlichen Augen in der
Luft können am Boden nicht nachgebildet
werden allein die Verzögerung von
Sekundenbruchteil beim Downlink und die
Fragilität der Sichtlinie in einem
hochkomplexen Kampfgebiet der uns zwei
fatale Achillesfersen des drohnenpiloten
in Bezug auf Kampfdrohnen ist wichtig zu
verstehen dass diese nicht vollkommen
autonom sein können es gibt immer
jemanden der ihre Bewegungen
kontrolliert und dieser jemand sitzt
meistens irgendwo auf der anderen Seite
der Erdkugel aktuelle kampfdrohen sind
also weniger Flugroboter und eher
ferngesteuerte Flugzeuge und wenn sie
mit Gegnern wie einem F35 Verbund
konfrontiert werden ist es extrem
schwierig die Integrität der Steuer- und
Feedback Signale aufrecht zu erhalten um
bemannte Kampfflugzeuge zu ersetzen
müssten diese Drohnen also wirklich
autonom sein und eigenständig
Entscheidungen treffen Skynet lässt
grüßen und wie schwierig es ist ein
wirklich vollkommen autonomes Fahrzeug
zu entwickeln muss Elon Musk aus der
eigenen tesla-praxis kennen Teslas
müssen dabei noch nicht mal Gegenden
rechnen die sie aktiv killen wollen
sondern nur mit der
Straßenverkehrsordnung kämpfen was meint
ihr wie sich der Tesla Autopilot gegen
eine F35 Staffel schlagen würde aber im
Ernst es gibt unter extremen Umständen
so viele Grenzfälle das ist fast
unmöglich ist sie vorherzusagen ein
Gefecht ist die dynamische Umgebung die
man sich vorstellen kann die unglaublich
hohe Zahl an unbekannten verhindert ein
vollständiges Verständnis des
Schlachtfelds hinzu kommt dass die
Software der Drohne einen Feind
überwinden musste absichtlich auf ihre
Schwächen abzielt und genau das ist
jenes Feld in dem das menschliche Gehirn
noch lange unüberwunden sein wird
empfinden dynamischer und kreativer
Lösungen für unbestimmte grenzwertige
und unvorhersehbare Probleme
die Fähigkeiten von bemannten und
unbemannten Kampfflugzeugen haben
derzeit auch mittelfristig eine dermaßen
kleine Schnittmenge das keine dieser
Technologien die jeweils andere auch nur
annähernd ersetzen kann die Zukunft
liegt also darin Wege zu finden wie
beide so nahtlos wie möglich
zusammenarbeiten können eine Luftwaffe
ohne eine ausreichende Zahl modernster
bemannter Kampfflugzeuge und
Kampfpiloten wird daher auch in den
kommenden Jahren und Jahrzehnten
hoffnungslos unterlegen sein und die F35
ist hier nun mal der Platzhirsch sorry
Mister Musk aber Skynet wird es so
schnell noch nicht geben so und ihr seid
mal wieder ihr an der Reihe glaubt ihr
dass die USA mit dem Verkauf der F35 an
ihre Verbündeten ein gutes Geschäft
machen wird auch auf lange Sicht wäre es
vielleicht möglich gewesen den NATO
Kampfjet auch für weniger Geld zu
entwickeln und ist eine effektive
Kostenkontrolle in der Militärindustrie
überhaupt denkbar schreibt uns bitte
alles was euch einfällt in die
Kommentare und falls euch dieses Video
gefallen hat vergesst bitte nicht zu
spenden damit wir dieses Projekt
weiterführen können natürlich freuen wir
uns auch über ein Like und wenn ihr
dieses Video mit euren Freunden teilt
wenn ihr keines unserer informativen
Videos mehr verpassen wollt klickt bitte
auch auf den Abo Button und auf das
kleine Glöck leichter Leben denn PayPal
Link zum Spenden findet ihr übrigens in
der Beschreibung unter dem Video und er
funktioniert auch wenn ihr kein Paypal
Konto habt Bank oder Kreditkarte reichen
vollkommen aus ich danke euch macht's
gut und bis bald